hello everybody hope they are good I
hope that you have a nice weekend today
is Monday um to be honest I also like
Mondays because for me Mondays mean the
start of a new trading week and it's
always kind of exciting and and and I
feel motivated so we're going to go a
bit through what has happened to Bitcoin
in the last few days uh because the last
video was on Friday but yesterday on
Sunday I also posted the Bitcoin Sunday
update the first thing that we uh
mention the uh Sunday update was um the
weekly levels we're going to go through
them in a minute but uh then at the end
of the Bitcoin soon date uh I posted
this projection uh it was a projection
where I saw this uh liquidity trend line
okay that every time it goes lower there
is more liquidity in here okay because
also in this area there is going to be
liquidity okay and it gets big and big
and big at that point so it was quite
normal that also after a sweep of the
lows um price tends to go again to the
range highs um that wasting you know a
little retrace you got that week there
okay also if you notice why we were
holding all the time the the 1 hour 50
ma that was a good entry then we break
above the trend line tested a support
you only had one retest you didn't have
uh many opportunities you got that
retest there and then uh we basically
touch the the Range High so that
projection completed um it's kind of
difficult to look at this range now and
try to make sense of what would of what
could happen next for that we need to
try to go into the weekly time frame
then I would also like to go um into
some altcoins and the Bitcoin dominance
because the Bitcoin dominance was a bit
tricky this weekend we were projecting
uh that the bitco dominance was going to
go down am money was going to be sifting
over the weekend from Bitcoin to
altcoins that happened you can see the
Bitcoin dominance is dropping like
nonstop since since Friday but right
after the video Bitcoin the bitcoiners
did something a bit strange and it was
this this push up okay that push-up C me
by surprise he temporarily invalidated
my charts in altcoins because price
broke below the 4our 50 may but then if
you go and check for example now Solana
okay you can see go to the 4our time
frame you can see how then recover the
4H hour 50 MAA and then price you know
started to that move that we were
talking about same is happening with
arbitrium check arbitrium all right
there you go you can see it here more
clearly because he also gave an entry
okay you got down Friday that little
surprise price breaking below the 4 or 5
me and and AR vitrium went quite lower
to be honest but then you got the
recovery on Sunday Sunday was a good day
test the the 50 May back a support and
then continuation uh on Sunday night all
right with chain link chaining didn't
move that much buto there you go you
lose temporarily the 4our 50 m recover
it tested a support and then you got the
little pump okay they didn't go as high
as I expected and also taking into into
consideration that Bitcoin is still
ranging but look at this mve here okay
that was at the same time as the Bitcoin
dominance was going up it was quite a
strange day Friday evening okay but
there you go also Bitcoin going down
there why why would Bitcoin go down hang
on look from
52,500 to 50,600 almost $2,000
drop on Friday evening it's very strange
okay and at the same time the Bitcoin
dominance went up and now you can see
Bitcoin continue ranging that's what we
were talking about and the Bitcoin
dominance going down but there is always
a few traps in the market um you just
have to be careful F that it doesn't
catch you by surprise and if it does
like it did to me then no problem you
have invalidation you C the trade or you
don't enter and then you enter again
when the trade is valid um but it was
quite interesting to mention this
because you can see how a strange that
pump was in the Bitcoin dominance while
Bitcoin went down on Friday evening
didn't make any sense okay but the
market is full of surprises and talking
about
surprises um we could also talk about
the weekly time frame let's go to the
weekly time frame guys so in the suay
update and also uh on the video that I
posted on Friday that was the last video
in the channel I was talking about this
resistance Zone here okay 52,000 and we
were talking that it was very important
for Bitcoin to close Above This level
because if it closes below this level
then the risk to the downside for this
week was going to increase quite a lot
now Bitcoin actually closed Above This
level because it Clos closed at 52,1 15
okay uh it closed about 52k I'm happy
with that okay that means that the risk
to the downside for this week is not as
as is not as high as if Bitcoin would
have closed the weekly uh Candlestick
below this level so we are good but I I
also mentioned the soon update that I
would like to see at least two
candlesticks closing Above This level so
it's very important that this week's
Candlestick also loses Above This level
above
52,000 if that's the case then it's very
likely that we see continuation to 60k
all right um that's what I mentioned
that we closed yesterday's uh C weekly
Candlestick above 52k doesn't mean that
we're going to go this week to 60k and
this is what I wanted to mention also
yesterday in the suay update and I think
I wrote it uh very clear that I would
like to see at least two weekly
candlesticks closing Above This level so
this week is going to be very important
to hold above above this level and it
the same goes for the other case okay if
we close this week below 52,000 then
okay let's see what happens in the next
week if again we close below 52,000 that
is telling me that it's very likely that
we drop back to this level that's 44,000
all right um but this goes about possib
about probabilities and having two
candlesticks closing above or below this
level is going to give a lot more
chances for that move to happen so
that's the thing that I wanted to
mention in the weekly time frame um all
I want to say is that pay attention to
this week's weekly Candlestick because
if we close now instead below
52,000 then careful with 44 okay because
yeah closing a couple of candlesticks
below 52k can trigger that move still so
we are not out of the woods also
remember that it's Monday we still still
have uh 7 days to go so but still if we
close this Candlestick also Above This
level then we could see 60k in the next
week or so all right so that's what I
wanted to mention high low Capital
liquidation levels let's do it quickly
you guys know the rule of the channel
liquidation levels first then
liquidation hit map the Delta is
basically neutral Delta liquidations
okay um during the ranges when we have a
range a lot of Lo positions uh get close
and also we had a a stop hunt so it
makes sense that the Delta is is back to
zero now back on Monday okay that's very
good because it basically uh resets the
the liquidity of the chart and we can
now see new moves now regarding the
liquidation spikes we can see some
levels are quite important 52,800
53,1
100 and I would also say to the downside
50,000 500 all right so these are the
levels of
Interest let's see if they in the
liquidation hit map so we can see
anything else 7 Days time frame let's
take
it um not very clear guys because we
have liquidations to the to the upside
and to the downside so there it's a
range okay so it's normal there are
going to be traders long in the range
there is going to be Traders short in
the range already so if normal that the
liquidations are appearing to both sides
but this doesn't give us much of a clue
because if all the liquidations were um
imagine if all the liquidations were to
the upside then you know it makes sense
that market maker triggers a move to the
upside to hit those liquidations but
because of the liquidations are also to
the downside and that means that there
are still traders long in this range
expecting you know 60k soon then there
is uh liquidations um to both sides now
it's quite interesting I'm not going to
lie that there are more Traders short in
this than long in okay or at least uh
this is what this chart is telling me
you notice there are more yellow bars
more liquidations to the upside that
means that there are more short
liquidations short liquidations are to
the upside long liquidations to the
downside so having more short
liquidations than long liquidations are
telling me that Traders are preferring
to short the range which uh in a way
um it could make sense um especially if
we close this week's uh weekly
Candlestick below 52k but right now I I
might think that that's a bit too
premature and there is a risk of a stop
hunt above the range SI to hit all these
liquidations first before dropping if
that's the real move of the market maker
all right so that's quite interesting
regarding liquidations now let's go very
quickly to the other book this is the
other book and I'm going to be very
quick with it because is quite clear is
it's basically showing liquidity at
53,000 okay 179 four Bitcoin worth of
limit sell orders now are those really
limit sell orders like is is that is
that really a sell wall or are those
going to be stop losses short
liquidations um to be honest we've had a
look at the at the range we've had a
look this is this is basically above the
range SI we've also have a look at high
Capital so in my opinion for what I seen
it makes sense that those are going to
be short liquidations and also a few
stop losses from Traders trading this
range thinking that we're going to break
to the downside okay so this is what I
mean are those Traders going open in
positions
prematurely and we're going to see a
stop hunt first to 53k or are they going
to be right and we're going to drop a
straight away so that is basically in my
opinion The Narrative um and the main
question of the of the current price
action I I don't want to discard a stop
hun 53,000 so we're going to back to the
Chart we're going to try to make sense
of all of this and see if we can come up
with a projection I'm back at the chart
to throw my final thoughts about what
it's possibly going on here and first of
all let me extend this range because I
think we're going to be ranging for a
bit for a while longer and the thing
that is uh worrying me the most about
this chart is this liquidity pool here
okay let's see if the indicator is
working yeah it is hang
on this is my indicator guys um I've
removed the trading sessions uh for now
um I can enable them if I want to very
quickly here but for right now i' I've
disabled them because I only want to see
what are the interesting levels of the
chart I can see some weeks here Taco fil
I don't really see any new weeks
here and here I see some some weeks that
got filed so regarding Wicks I don't
really see any Wick of importance of
interest but I see this liquidity pull
to the downside also notice how this
move down that we saw on that Friday
evening that I told you was quite a
strange move it went exactly to this uh
candle here okay it didn't start to
retrace the the liquidity pool it feels
as if they are leaving it for later on
okay uh that's basically what they did
because if we started to jump into this
liquidity pool then it's very likely
that price wouldn't have recovered the
range and once it Tes this liquidity
pool and it starts recovering it it
would have make sense to continue
retracing the whole thing so it feels
like we're leaving this liquidity pool
for later now what that makes me think
is that we're going to continue this
range for a for a for a while longer the
market maker is in my opinion going to
play with impatience uh traders that
going to start to open positions and
then they're going to decide what to do
next but remember there is a lot of
liquidity at 53,000 in the other book in
hlo capital those are impatient Traders
opening positions already all right
especially because we've just retested
the range highs so they're thinking time
to short and they are not wrong with the
idea but they have to be careful that we
don't see something like this okay
because if that's the case they're going
to get stopped or liquidated before they
see their move playing out okay and I
will be to this liquidity pull at
50,000 which it would surprise me that
we don't hit that level again uh it's uh
just think about it guys it's a whole
number 50,000 it sounds very strong it's
going to be a level where a lot of
Traders are going to engage with price
let me remove my indicator go to the 4
hours time frame and we didn't spend
that much time okay only the only here
and that was since
Monday Monday to Tuesday St two days
playing in this area don't you think
that it would make more sense to
continue playing around this level for a
bit longer to me yes okay that's what I
think that in my opinion is more likely
that we go again towards this level
50,000 but I don't discard first to see
some kind of move like this okay that
stop H can happen and any Traer that has
already open shorts they have to be
careful with that and also have to be
careful with what I've been telling you
second weekly Candlestick closing about
52,000 there if we close this weekly
Candlestick above 52,000 then it's
pointless to favor any shorts we should
favor Longs still and yes they the chart
looks ere extended but come on if you
just flipped a resistance into support
what would you be
shorten all right so I think that next
week we're going to know more than we
know now and also in the coming days for
sure but for right now guys just trade
the range okay that's basically what I
would say keep an eye also on the 1 hour
50 ma if we can hold this level and we
come again to the range SI and we are
playing against the range SI like this
over the next few hours that is
basically going to tell me Spike up hit
53,000 all those stop losses because
just think about it guys any Trader
short in the top of the range where are
they placing their stop losses well
they're thinking about it and they are
thinking let me see well I'm going to
place my stop losses
here right above this white line and
also right above this Spike here because
that was the last high and oh 53,000
it's a good number I'm going to place
them there because I'm not going to
place my stop at 52,900 I'm going to
place it at
53,000 that's how the retail mind works
so keep an eye for this scenario if we
play again around the around the range
highs while the 50 EMA in the one hour
time frame is holding our support then
very likely that we hit that liquidity
at 53,000 okay then after that we'll
check if that was a stop hunt we drop
again back below this white line that
basically would trigger a short for me
aiming for this liquidity pull down to
50K simple as that okay um I might post
a post about this on Twitter later if
that's the case if we start to see
something like this if we something like
this I'll post my idea of what could
happen after 53k all the triggers so you
can also have that in text and only on
video anyway this video is getting too
long I'm going to close it here thank
you so much guys for watching and I'll
see you soon